have you ever wondered how people make
their photos look so good well today I'm
gonna teach you how to color great like
a professional what's going on guys my
name is Dave Thomas and welcome back to
the channel today we're going to look at
how you can color great your photos like
professional we're going to be using
Adobe Lightroom you can use it either on
your desktop or your mobile but today's
purposes we're gonna jump straight into
the desktop version and get started okay
so if you ever wondered how people turn
their photos from something like this
into something amazing like this it
actually isn't too hard and it doesn't
take much longer than maybe 2 or 3
minutes so for the purposes of this
video we're gonna take this photo back
to its original state this is how it was
shot it was shot against the Sun very
dark very underexposed and originally I
thought it was unusable but thankfully
this photo was shot in RAW which means
you can bring out a lot of the shadows
and highlights back into play so in
Adobe Lightroom you're gonna see this
panel on the right hand side this is
where your main functions are and this
is what you're gonna need to use the
most don't be intimidated by the fact
there's quite a few settings here it
gets very simple to use after a couple
of times of trying it out the first
thing you want to do is remove any
chromatic aberration and also enable
profile Corrections so with my camera it
picks up what camera it is and what lens
it is which makes it very easy and
efficient for me to do for every photo
time time again the second thing you
want to do with almost every photo is
tap the level correction in this case
it's moved a level a little bit too far
and we need to also take the crop
constraint but simply straight away you
can tell that the photo is now centered
its level with the horizon and there
doesn't need to be too many more
adjustments after this you want to
scroll to the top and get started on the
basic Corrections of the photo so as
we've already said this photo is
underexposed
and the highlights are blown out so
we're gonna remove the highlights
bringing them back to about maybe - 60 -
65 somewhere there and bringing the
shadows up as much as we can without
overdoing it if you go to 100 you're
gonna notice that it starts to get a bit
too
and he loses a lot of the clarity in the
blacks so we're gonna bring it back down
to maybe 70 70 percent in the positive
and because we can see straight away
that bringing up the shadows has
destroyed the contrast and destroyed the
blacks we're gonna drop the blacks down
a little bit lower to try get some more
deep rich colors in this photo and also
bring up the contrast a little bit more
to make it a bit punchier if you've
never used an s-curve before it's a very
simple process to use down the bottom
here is all your shadows this section
here is your mid-tones and at the very
top is your highlights
so as you adjust each section is how its
gonna change that particular part of the
photo I always start with a three-point
s-curve so for me it's three points
across the middle starting with the
shadows at the bottom the shadows
usually are bumped up a little bit just
to bring out that extra little bit
that's been lost in the details and then
dropping the blacks down a little bit
more so it starts to create that S shape
I normally don't touch too many of the
mid-tones because this is usually around
the face and the skin tones in most of
my photography but I do play with the
highlights a little bit as well so if we
bring the highlights down you're gonna
notice that the sky comes into clarity a
bit more and that we were able to remove
the harshness for the Sun and that's
pretty much all you have it for my s
curve in this photo you can also drop it
down and go to the red-green-blue
filters which gives you different
overlays and for example if we put a red
filter in you start to get those deep
blues and the shadows which is a very
trendy theme on Instagram at the moment
all the Reds coming through in the faces
if you're looking for the cinematography
a little bit aged shot you can go that
as well but personally I don't like them
at all so I don't add any reds greens or
blues into the photo itself now this is
where the fun starts you really can get
creative with the colors and the
saturation in your photo so for me I
personally always start with saturation
and try to make the mood of the photo
work to the best of my advantage
in this one you can tell the reds are
mainly in my face and and a little bit
in the skintone so we don't buff them up
too much I always have a tendency to
move my sliders up to maximum just to
understand where the colors are in that
photo and how much I really want to move
them up so in this one you can tell that
it's in the orange and the trees and
also in my face so we pump it up a
little bit to about 30% same as the
yellows I think they're prominently
coming out and this little Sun flash
straight down the middle of the photo so
we're going to bump it up to maybe about
10% not much more than that the greens
is always the trees usually but it isn't
really bringing out too much accepting
the Sun flare so we're not going to
bring that one up pretty much at all if
you're using the desktop version a good
trick is just double click on the slider
or the name of the color itself to reset
it without having to try line it back up
with the zero the actors in this photo
are going to be the start of the ocean
and the Blues are gonna be the same
merging into the sky we don't want to
overdo it
here so we're gonna just leave the blues
and aquas about 20% the purples is
something I always have a tendency to
remove almost to the bottom usually in
between fifty and a hundred percent in
the minus side because in my camera I
found that it's predominantly the
chromatic aberration in my photo so a
tendency to remove my purples and
magentas as much as possible
now if we move over to the hues of the
photo from memory that the Reds the
orange and the yellows are the primary
colors in this photo and the blue is in
the background so if we want to make the
blues a little bit more of a teal color
just to give it more of a vibrant pop
and the greens a little bit more vibrant
as well whereas the yellows and the
oranges we're not gonna move too much
but you can tell that in the face it is
a little bit too orange so we're gonna
move it slightly to the yellow side to
try to get those natural skin colors
back into play so only for in the Plus
on the oranges all it takes in this
photo split toning is one of the things
that you don't need to do in any
standard photo grading but it is
something that you'll see in most
professional level photo edits so adding
a hue to your highlights and your
shadows is very similar to using the s
but you have a bit more control in your
colors so to really understand what it
does we're going to pump it up to about
40% and slide the hue across because
this photo is taken outside near the
ocean I really want to reflect those
blues into the sky and into the
highlights a little bit more but
obviously not having it at such a high
saturation so putting a tiny little bit
of blue at about 10% is perfect for this
photo whereas the shadows we want to add
a little bit more orange to get a bit
more vibrance of the Sun coming through
now we can see that this photo is pretty
crisp there's a little bit of noise
coming through so we're only gonna add a
little bit of luminance to take away the
noise and they can even shop a photo now
obviously these photos for most people
will be going up on Instagram so the
last thing that we need to do is do the
crop overlay go original 4 by 5 which is
the Instagram crop filter and then
adjust at how you want it and that's all
there is to it guys so in less than 5
minutes we've managed to take a photo
from almost unusable to an Instagram
banger there really isn't much more to
it than that guys you can apply the same
principle to almost any photo you have
on your phone or straight off your DSLR
camera if you enjoyed this video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
20-19 style and I'll see you next Monday
for a brand new econ video